[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
بتتولد مستعيله كلها سم وبتطلع صاحبه صوت
مميز بتتمنى تبقى مغنيه لكنها حرفيا صوت
عيلتها هتختار حلمها ولا عيلتها وهل بعد
كل التضحيات اللي بتقدمها عيلتها هتدعمها
في قرارها ولا هيظهر الجانب الاناني من
الانسان ودمره حلمها اهلا بك في حلقه
جديده من بودكاستماره الافلام انا محمود
النجار والنهارده هاخدك في رحله لمورى
الصمت والكلام الغناء والمشاعر قصه مليانه
حكايات مثيره لعيله مميزه هحكي لك عن كودا
في البدايه خليني اقول لك ان الفيلم بعيد
من عنوانه وبيحكي قصته بكلمه واحده او
هكذا انت متخيل يعني الفيلم اتسمى كودا
اختصارا ليه
وده ببساطه مصطلح بيطلق على الطفل المولود
لعائله صماء ولكنه بيسمع بطل القصه هي
روبي بنت جميله
وبتهرب من الفصل لكنها بترجع بعدها للمدرس
وبتوضح له ليه هي عملت كده وانها كانت
خايفه من تنمر زمايلها ونظريتهم لها
المدرس بيفهم ده جدا وهنا بيجي دور مساعد
البطل والشخص الداعم له في كل حاجه علشان
يحقق غايته مستر في مستر في لما بيسمع صوت
روبي بيقول لها ان هي مميزه ولازم تستثمر
في صوتها وتهتم بحضور الحصص لان ده
هيساعدها تدخل كليه موسيقيه روبي بتتحمس
جدا ولكن على النقيض الاخر امها هتسخر
منها تماما لما روبي بتحكي لها عندها
والحقيقه ممكن ده شيء يبان طبيعي لانهم
عمرهم ما سمعوا صوتها قبل كده بس هنا
خلينا نتكلم شويه عن فكره العيله والدعم
والتقبل ايه علاقه البطله باهلها اخوها
الكبير امها ابوها روبي علاقتها باخوها
علاقه مميزه ولكن اخوها دايما بيحس انه
قليل قصادها خاصه انها حرفيا صوت العيله
وشايف انها المفروض تعيش حياتها ومش ملزمه
تفضل معهم مقابل تدمير احلامها الشخصيه ام
روبي في البدايه هتكون شخص اناني او زي ما
روبي قالت لها في لحظه غضب انت فاكره ان
كل حاجه بتدور حواليك وبناء على ده فهي
هترفض تماما فكره ان روبي تقدم في كليه
موسيقيه وسابهم وتمشي على العكس تماما
علاقه روبي بوالدها علاقه معتدله هو فاهم
وداعم بس ما فيش بيض حيله وفي وسط صراع
روبي مع اهلها ومع المدرسه وانها عايزه
تحقق احلامها لكنها برضو مش عايزه تسيب
اهلها بسبب خوف عليهم الامور بتسوء في
الشغل والحكومه بتفرض على كل صياد مراقب
يكون على المركب ولسوء حظه روبي وعالتها
ان في اليوم اللي روبي مش هتروح فيه
المركب المراقب هيطلع معاهم رحله صيد
وخلال الرحله دي المراقبه بتكتشف ان بسبب
صم العيله فهم غير قادرين على ممارسه مهنه
الصيد تماما من غير ما يعرضوا نفسهم او
اللي حواليهم لمشاكل وبالتالي بلغت عنهم
وده عرض مهنه العيله كلها للخطر والحكومه
فرضت عليهم وجود شخص بيسمع على السفينه
بشكل مستمر ولو فاكر ان دي حاجه سهله
فللاسف لا لان الشخص ده لازم يكون كمان
قادر يتواصل معهم وفاهم لغه الاشاره في
الوقت ده روبي بتقرر تتخلى عن حلمها وانها
مش لازم تروح الكليه بعد ما ياست في انها
تحاول تظبط الامور من الناحيتين لكن اللي
هيحصل بسبب الازمه اللي فرضتها الحكومه
على الصيادين في اجتماع الصيادين والد
روبي هيقوم يصرخ في الكل وروبي بترجم
كلامه وهيشجع الصائدين انهم يستقلوا عن
استغلال الحكومه ويبيعوا بدعتهم بنفسهم
وهنا هيظهر تحدي جديد العيله بعد ما كانت
بتخسر شغلها عملوا بزنس الصغير ناجح وضمه
معاهم الصيادين وظهر هنا مشاكل زي ان ام
روبي ما كانتش قادره تندمج مع المجتمع او
صعوبه ظهورهم في لقاء التليفزيونيه من غير
روبي لكن وسط كل ده روبي بتقدر تقاتل في
الناحيتين ناحيه مع اهلها وناحيه مع
استاذها اللي بجد زهق من تقصيرها وتاخيرها
الدائم وبعد احداث كتير محتاج تشوفها ومش
هحكيلك عنها هنا روبي بتروح الاختبار
وبيروح معاها اهلها ايه اللي حصل وهل نجحت
تدخل الكليه ولا لا ده اللي هتعرفه وتعيش
تفاصيله اكتر
المشاهد مش هتنساها لما تشوف الفيلم
دلوقتي خلينا نتكلم عن ما وراء الفيلم
فيلم كودا من تاليف واخراج سيان هدر واعاد
انتاجه باللغه الانجليزيه للفيلم الفرنسي
البلجيكي لافاميل بالياغ ادمن دور البطوله
ايميليا جونز بدون روبي روزي وفي الفيلم
ظهر ممثلين
اللي كانوا بيتواصلوا مع جونز باستخدام
لغه الاشاره الامريكيه فشوفنا تمثيل
في الادوار الداعمه الفيلم كان انتاج دولي
مشترك ما بين الولايات المتحده وفرنسا مع
لافاميل بليارد وتم تصويره في الموقع في
الولايات المتحده كان العرض الاول لفيلم
كودا في 28 يناير سنه 2021 في مهرجان
هي اللي حصلت على حقوق التوزيع الخاصه به
مقابل مبلغ قياسي قيمته 25 مليون دولار تم
اصدار الفيلم في الثوره العرض وكمان على
ابل تي في بلس ب 13 اغسطس سنه 2021 ولو
بتسال عن راي النقاد في الفيلم خليني اقول
الفيلم بعد نزوله انقاد قالوا اراء
ايجابيه ولكن في المقابل المشاهدين الصم
كانوا متضايقين شويه من الفيلم وفي
النهايه تم اختيار الفيلم كواحد من افضل
10 افلام لعام 2021 من قبل المعهد
الامريكي للافلام وتم الاشاده بالسيناريو
والاداء فاز فيلم كودا بالعديد من الجوائز
بما في ذلك ترشيحات الثلاثه اللي تلقاها
في حفل توزيع جوائز الاوسكار رقم 94 عن
افضل صوره وافضل ممثل مساعد وافضل سيناريو
مقتبس وحصل الفيلم ايضا على جائزه
وجايزه
لافضل سيناريو مقتبس في حين فاز الممثلين
بجائزه نقابه ممثلي الشاشه عن الاداء
المتميز اللي قدمه فريق كاستنام وفي
النهايه فيلم كودا تجربه ثريه وممتعه جدا
محتاج تشوفها وتستمتع بكل التفاصيل
[موسيقى]